during the first Democratic presidential
debates in June
moderator Lester Holt asked the same
question to both sets of candidates who
here insurance in favor of a
government-run plan just to show this
question was referring to Medicare for
all a proposal by senator Bernie Sanders
that would create a new federally run
healthcare system and make the US
government the sole provider of health
insurance in the United States under
senator Sanders plan most employees
sponsored private insurance would be
eliminated and Medicare would be
replaced with an entirely new program
one that covers health care costs for
every single person in the United States
this question about private insurance
has dominated the presidential debate on
the Left all candidates say they want
universal health care meaning they want
every American covered but they're split
on how to get there just look at how
they answered the question
senators Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris
New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio and senator
Elizabeth Warren all raised their hands
to say they would eliminate private
insurance but several co-sponsors of
Medicare for all legislation from both
the House and Senate were on stage both
nights and didn't raise their hands and
Kamala Harris walked back her answer
after the debate by saying she
misunderstood the question
that's because several candidates have
expressed concerns about Medicare for
all and are embracing different
approaches to universal coverage showing
that this debate isn't just Medicare for
all or nothing we're going to explain
what Medicare for all is what it isn't
and what other Democratic health care
proposals would do to health insurance
in the United States the problems
surrounding the conversation around
Medicare for all is that many people
really just don't understand what
Medicare for all means so well Medicare
for all really does kind of refer to one
specific broad idea there are a lot of
percolating ways to get there that have
been kind of carried under the umbrella
of Medicare for all you can think of
health care as a spectrum on one side
you have medicare for all single-payer
system and on the other side you have
private insurance the current system in
the United States falls in between the
two with a mix of
and government-sponsored insurance that
operate alongside each other Democrats
have gotten himself boxed into this
corner about whether their health plans
would get rid of private insurance
that's kind of been the issue that has
taken over the general focus this is
significant because the vast majority of
Americans have private health insurance
a little more than one hundred and fifty
six million Americans receive employer
sponsored insurance through work and
private health insurance covers over
one-third of all medical costs in the
United States Medicare for all would
introduce public insurance that would
muscle out employer sponsored insurance
over four years it would also cover the
uninsured creating a single-payer system
by leaving very little room for what
private insurance could offer the
question about whether your health plan
would get rid of private plans has taken
up a lot of air in the room when in fact
if you look at other countries the vast
majority have a system that still allows
for private plans for supplemental
coverage Medicare for all would ban most
private insurance from offering the same
coverage as the government but England
has a universal health care system that
allows private insurance to offer
duplicate coverage this private
insurance provides access to private
hospitals and reduces wait times for
certain treatments senator Sanders has
pointed to Canada's health care system
as a model his plan would emulate but
Canada has a private insurance industry
that offers supplemental health
insurance to cover things the government
doesn't like vision in dental care about
two-thirds of Canadians have
supplemental private health insurance
Medicare for all would be more expansive
than its Canadian counterpart covering
dental and vision services the only
out-of-pocket expense would be a copay
on prescription drugs that would be
capped at two hundred dollars per year
patients with government-funded
insurance in both France and Australia
also incur some sort of out-of-pocket
cost but private health insurance is
available in both places to cover these
costs about 95 percent of people in
France have this complimentary private
insurance in addition to government
insurance
under thee for example planned by
senator bernie sanders it does have a
very very limited role for private
insurance more limited than what you
would see in other countries a big
question about medicare for all is how
you pay for it the idea that it's been
proposed by senator bernie sanders does
have some ideas attached to it no
specific funding mechanism but it looks
at a progressive tax attacks on
companies he has said that taxes would
increase overall to pay for the plan yes
they will pay more in taxes but less in
health care for what they got there was
a lot of other plans out there that
Democrats are supporting supporting
including options that would let
everybody or limited number people buy
into a plan like Medicare I believe we
need to get to universal health care as
a right and not a privilege to
single-payer the quickest way you get
there is you create competition with the
insurers while Medicare for all
aggressively builds a new single-payer
system from the ground up other plans
expand the existing Medicare program to
cover everyone in the u.s. these ideas
are considered more of a stepping stone
to this idea of universal health care
that the Democrats do support as their
overall goal under these plans private
insurance remains the Medicare for
America Act automatically enrolls the
uninsured and newborns into Medicare but
allows employers to continue to offer
private insurance however workers can
also choose to enroll in Medicare
premiums would remain but with caps and
those close to the poverty line would
receive subsidies the choose Medicare
Act allows Medicare to be bought through
health care exchanges set up by the ACA
private insurance could remain as long
as it was gold level coverage a level of
coverage where insurance covers 80% of
costs out-of-pocket costs would be
capped at seventy nine hundred dollars
per year the goal would be to level the
playing field and make private insurance
compete with a public option some of the
research that have been has been done on
Medicare buying plans do show that the
premiums for these would be lower than
what's currently offered on the
individual individual markets one of the
hope of support
of some of these buying options is that
because they would be more affordable
that more people would buy into these
plans they would find them palatable
they would find them things they could
afford and this would be a kind of slow
on-ramp toward a universal healthcare
system or Medicare for all this is
really the first time in our country's
history that we are looking at a total
revamping of the US healthcare system
and it's the first time it's become
really part of the public debate it
could affect you the consumer it could
affect how much you pay out-of-pocket
your ability to get access and coverage
even after the election no matter who
wins this is going to be an issue that
continues to get debated for quite some
time
[Music]